so first thing I'd like to do is set
some expectations on what's going to
happen here I'd have to add this in I
hadn't thought about with cryptocurrency
we won't be talking about cryptocurrency
what I hope to give you is a working
understanding of some of the terms the
common terms used and the key drivers
for choosing cryptography methodologies
algorithms and strengths so you won't
leave here being an expert
hopefully you'll leave here with enough
information to make intelligent
decisions about what you're doing with
cryptography so the first thing we
should go over is what is cryptography
and if you're like me the first thing
that you do is you go look at Wikipedia
and Wikipedia has this moderate
moderately well defined definition it's
the practice and study of techniques to
secure communications and the presence
of third parties called adversaries and
what I like to focus on is the fact that
we're securing communications and that
there are adversaries right you don't
have to study it unless you're a
cryptographer you don't need to study
cryptography but it's important to
understand that what you're trying to do
is you're trying to secure communication
even that even if that's just
communication with yourself storing on a
hard drive sticking in memory across the
network to yourself it's still
communicating and it's there are
adversaries that will try and get it so
how cryptography works the first thing
to understand that cryptography all
starts with secrets
so secrets are an essential part of
practical cryptography you can have
cryptography without secrets it's just
not a very good idea but secret has been
in use for more than cryptography as
well right there's very old stories
about using pass phrases to gain
entrance to things a very famous what
does the Open Sesame
to be able to gain access and that was a
secret
right in the United States during
Prohibition times or places called
speakeasies where you could actually go
consume alcohol because you couldn't
anywhere else and you would have to have
a proper passphrase to know that they
weren't going to you weren't an official
trying to arrest them
in ancient cryptography they used
methods the cryptography methods were
secret
and so you would have to know the method
but that was the secret part all right
how you would actually go from the
plaintext the cipher tax from the
ciphertext back to the plaintext that
was the secret in modern cryptography
the methodologies are well-known they're
documented they are peer-reviewed they
go through this large process to be
accepted and they're published in
academic journals and oftentimes they're
turned into if they succeed and they're
accepted they turn into distributable
libraries in PHP we have M crypt open
SSL and sodium and there are others so
secrets that in modern cryptography is
done in the form of keys and those are
what we we use to add to an algorithm to
turn plaintext in the ciphertext and
back the other way
generating and exchanging keys though
can be a tricky business before the mid
70s 1970s passing secrets was a thing
that people did with briefcases and
handcuffs and long trips as he would
have someone with the secret with the
codes in in World War 2 it was code
books you would have to just pass around
these large you had to pass around
secrets so that both of you knew what
the secret was for today or the secret
was for this time or the secret was for
this message so in modern cryptography
to make that usable and affordable and
accessible probably the most critical
advance would be key exchange so some of
you are familiar with diffie-hellman key
exchange and what diffie-hellman key
exchange is is the ability for two
people to have a secret value to be able
to come up with a known common value but
never pass the value across the wire so
when you make a connection to a web
server that uses
TLS often fir - as ssl this is what's
going on in the background all right
this is the diffie-hellman key exchange
and it's a process I won't get all into
it you can read about it that's actually
a picture from Wikipedia so there's
really good information on Wikipedia on
how that actually works I've also got
some references to some books that go
through it really well - but it's a it's
a it's a way to actually come up with a
common secret from your own secrets
never pass them around you can both
communicate in a secure manner and to do
this is very expensive it's just using
prime numbers very large prime numbers
and modular arithmetic so it's kind of
this black box of magic that happens
which isn't so important for us to
understand today just understand that
it's this is what happens and you're
exchanging a key and key exchange is a
really big important thing if you've
ever had to converse with a with a third
party like if you use Amazon or if you
use github you're communicating over TLS
via SSH using SSH key you have to key it
to move that thing back and forth that
key which can make it difficult key
exchange make this loose you don't have
to do that the next super awesome piece
of voodoo mathematics that came about
was public/private key pairs and this is
so you don't have to exchange secrets so
much like key exchange the
diffie-hellman key exchange says I have
a secret do you have a secret we're
going to create a combined secret public
private key cryptography says that I
have a secret I'll give you just enough
to do it you have to do on your side and
then you'll give me your a public key
which has just enough information to do
the same the most famous one of this is
called RSA named after the three
inventors of the product of the process
also before they invented this there's
actually a British mathematician that
came up with it basically design the
same thing before they did but it was
super secret because it was part of
British intelligence so he was not
allowed to tell anybody for a very long
time but
symmetric key cryptography which is what
the public/private key pair is talked
about made it's this you didn't have to
do that key exchange so it made a lot
easier to move data without having to do
this complicated process of doing key
exchange and building that in the other
part of cryptography is ciphers so keys
and ciphers so we see some ancient
ciphers here on the left that's just
basically our placement on the top right
is that is rot13 I believe know what is
it rot 3 yes
very very simple but that used to be
considered acceptable cryptography 20
years ago and in the bottom that's RSA
so modern cryptography ciphers use
mathematics very complicated mathematics
and we'll get into that a bit more later
just to understand that it's all math
it's why you need computers to do it
it's because it's all mathematics there
are different ways that cryptography is
used and we'll go over that as well so
the important things that we'll talk
about that are happen in a daily life of
a developer someone who is writing
applications are going to be encryption
digital signatures key derivation and
hashing and key derivation is what a lot
of people call password hashing even in
PHP libraries we call it password
hashing it is hashing but it's a process
of doing multiple hashes in different
methodologies for generating keys so
they call it key duration so encryption
encryption is used to place data in a
form that can be reconstituted into its
original form so what it can be
encrypted can also be decrypted it comes
in two flavors symmetric which is a
shared key and a symmetric which is
public key encryption so an asymmetric
encryption you have a shared secret I'm
sorry yes an asymmetric encryption you
do not
have a shared secret that's symmetric
encryption asymmetric encryption have
your own set of keys and they're
different and what you're going to do is
you're going to use a public key to
encrypt data for a private key and
digital signatures go the other way
around
I'll get more in depth than that in just
a moment symmetric encryption is where
you share a same secret the same key
same Keys used to encrypt it is to
decrypt hashing is where you create a
representation of the value and it
cannot be reversed it's reproducible if
it's a proper hash but it cannot be
reversed so when you hash something it
doesn't normally have enough information
to regenerate it now this particular
input the input is smaller than the hash
but more often if you see when you're
downloading a file and you see that it
has an md5 or sha-1 representation and
there's not enough information to
recreate it but the function allows you
to come up with a string of the same
length every single time and the
difference between a good input hash and
a bad one is how well how well it
prevents collision what you don't want
is you don't want two things having the
same hash it will happen because just
the way to algorithms work you're just
going to have that so the larger your
hash the better the algorithm the less
likely you are to be able to create that
and we'll get into that more also and a
modern hashing algorithm won't create an
input role credit collision for an input
whose size is equal to or less than the
value of the hash so because it's the
same size you can't have a collision
it's only one it's larger so if you have
a 30 character string and you're doing a
48 character hash you never have to be
concerned about collisions because they
just can't happen on a proper algorithm
so in our example our input size is less
than our output size it means it would
be impossible to create another hash but
if you have a larger value like this
image it's condensing it down
and there's a popular attack that's been
recent called shattered say one hurt or
shattered all right we do have crypto
geeks okay
so shattered is it is possible using a
PDF to adjust the headers in the PDF
until you can have a different document
with the same hash so you're taking
something I just not necessary the same
size and you're you're condensing it
down to the point where you can keep
adjusting the headers you you would
change the what the document is and
oftentimes that is I agree to do
something or the terms of a document so
if you sign a document if you sign a PDF
and you hash that that should be secure
except if you're depending on what
you're hashing it with and shattered is
for a sha-1 which is an older hash you
can create the new document that you
want to interpret as being signed make
the brute and do brute force you make a
hash does it match no change the headers
does it match now no change the header
does it match now it's possible albeit
expensive so in order to do that I did
the math on AWS and before discounts it
would cost about $10,000 in GPU rental
on AWS and it would take a week so it's
a lot of these things we mean when you
hear about things that are possible to
do it's it's it's getting easier now
that anyone can go rent ten thousand
GPUs but it's still prohibitive and
there are also ways around that you can
use this shot too and use another hash
as well an md5 so if you hatch it twice
using two different algorithms and you
have two different values it's nearly
impossible to find one not impossible
but nearly impossible to find one that
you could be able to create both with
that would take a lot more time hashes
although fantastic by themselves aren't
terribly useful because all the hash
tells you is that that is this that is
the data that you have you got so if I
download a file and the hash match is
fantastic
that's the that's the actual data there
was there
but who's to know that the hash didn't
change with the data so on an attacker
uploaded a new file that has malware in
it and then generated a new hash it's
perfectly central I'll download it I'll
verify the hash the data is good so what
you want at that point is digital
signatures digital signatures are hash
mixed with a key with a function that
uses a key so it's not like you would
just stick the key on stick - off and so
that's going to verify the integrity of
data as well as the fact that the
individual that you are assuming created
that the data do create the data and so
a digital signature looks very simple
like a hash so these are hmx and it
follows the same thing and there are
some rules that have to be required for
an HM AK and that is that if you have
the same data with the same key you get
the same signature every single time
that's kind of a requirement if you have
the same data with a different key you
get a different signature because that's
to prevent someone from being able to
say here's the data you got from person
a but person B signed it and if you also
if you have different data it will be
different as well so it's very similar
to hashing although it's putting that
key in there that secret value that no
one else should be able to know that can
tell you that I'm signing it and as it's
me as an individual signing it so if you
are if you sign your github commits
which I have - you're doing this you're
saying that I as an individual signed
this and you can trust that this commit
was made by me not because it just has
my email and my name on there because
anybody can put that in but because I
have been I have provided github with my
public key and it can verify the
signature that I made with my private
key against the data key duration is
another really good use of hashing
functions so key derivations are
cyclical hashes where the hash is fed
into the
lower them over and over again to
generate a brand new hash it's done many
times to require a lot of computing
power the idea behind it is to in
require a lot of computing power hashes
should be very fast if I need to verify
data I should be able do that very
quickly the faster the better
however for passwords I don't want you
to be able to try them constantly over
over and over again I wanted to be very
difficult for you to be able to
brute-force a password so key derivation
by by design is very computationally
expensive and it also uses in good
methodologies for key derivation they
use random values called salts and the
salts are used as well over and over
again to create this different value and
I'll show you a very oversimplified
value or oversimplified example of why
that's necessary so I hate passwords is
actually one the top passwords in use
today mixed with a random salt get you a
random value the hashed value you take
the hashed value in the salt you get
another value and you do it again and
again and again and so that's how you're
generating you're basically going over
and over again to make it
computationally expensive which is
important because the way that passwords
work is you're trying to give your users
time to change them one of the nice
things about passwords as opposed to
biometrics is you can change them it's
important to secure these things in such
a manner to buy your users time so if
your site gets attacked and you may just
have a simple blog site and you and many
people think well I just have a simple
blog site what do I care
unfortunately your users probably use
their email as the username and they
probably use the same password for their
email that they did on your blog most
people don't know better and that's what
they do
and if I can hack your site and get
their password and I have their email
and then I can get their their email
account I can now do password resets on
every other thing that I want to have
access to those because those are always
sent to email so I can get their bank
account I can get their credit cards I
can get enough information from their I
can get on to their their shared drives
where they probably have their tax
statements that have person identifiable
information and enough to impersonate
them however I like so if you only have
a very simple site that you require
people to log in to try and be very
careful with what you do with their
passwords because again if if users are
impersonating people on your site you
may not care but your users don't know
security and they're doing terrible
things like some of you may also have
just gotten very scared when I told that
as I did when I was first told these
types of things I didn't know any better
I figured well I'll have certain types
of passwords and that'll keep me safe
but again it's important to as you're do
using these key derivation functions you
want to make them as strong as you
possibly can as many iterations as you
can stand because what that means is is
if you if you're using the the password
functions in PHP as you go through a
large number of iterations every time I
want to try and attack your passwords I
have to do a large number of iterations
every single time for each attempt a
brute-force so how many people here
remember Ashley Madison the talk about
Ashley Madison all right all right
that's a little or popular so Ashley
Madison was a website for non-marital
affairs most of the individuals most of
the men on this site were marital they
were also because of the way the site
work they tended to be unusually
important a large number of military
government and high-level c-class
executives information was found on this
site and it used B was PHP and it used
the password function which meant it was
very secure so the people attacking it
after they were able to
there's there's this thing called the
top 100 passwords it's a list that
people keep updated from things they've
been able to attack they said I'll try
the first 100 which gives you anywhere
from 10 to 30% of the password base and
then they just stopped because it's just
too expensive to try and just
brute-force all the other passwords one
character at a time until they found a
back door because they had left in a
separate hash non key derivation that
was built using the username and the
unencrypted password and the unhatched
password which was just a sha-1 and so
using that using the known username and
the known the symbol in there they were
able to just generate everybody's
passwords so always important Keter
Batian because attackers will just walk
away more often than not because they
know that by the time they are able to
crack it the users will change most
users will change their passwords that's
why cuter evasion isn't important so
getting good cryptography we have a kind
of basic understanding of how
cryptography works the key to your own
implications will be using good
cryptography and his cryptography has
been used for centuries with varying
levels of success
many of us have likely used bad
cryptography at some point and if you're
as old as I am
it may have often been good cryptography
when you started using it right that's
like using an md5 or a sha for password
12 years ago using a salted sha-1 for a
password was considered the best
password security available and it was
just fine but today I can crack that on
my phone so
as technology increases so does the the
need to make use better cryptography but
it's important I think for you to
understand what makes good cryptography
because what is good cryptography
changes throughout the years it will
change and change and change and change
PS PHP 7/2 is taking us to a new level
of cryptography with live sodium but
it's important to understand why it's
important and what makes it good so good
cryptography makes it obscures data in
such a way that it's difficult and
costly to duplicate a reverse alright
just we talked about with the key
derivation it's making it very expensive
to try and get someone's password when
you're using algorithms you want them to
be very costly and difficult because
it's going to make it harder and there's
a very good reason for that and we'll
talk about kind of how this works and
why it's important into two different
sections entropy and computational cost
and well if you don't what entropy means
we'll get to that as well they're
independent as well as interdependent so
things that can be can have good entropy
have nothing to do with the computation
but together they create good
cryptography so when attacking it
there's two ways that you can attack
cryptography one is pattern analysis the
other one is brute force and pattern
analysis is you often hear it referred
to as crypt analysis that's taking some
information you know about the subject a
raw subject and seeing if you can
determine patterns and the other one is
just trying it again
is this it know is this it know this it
no that's brute force
so brute force is much like smacking a
rock with a hammer if you hit a rock
with a hammer long enough the rock will
break depending on the size of the
hammer is how long it will take all
right because you can sit there with a
very small hammer or just keep it in the
rock if you've seen very small streams
cut through rock over centuries
it's possible it's just difficult and
costly in cryptography it's just trying
it over and over again all right is this
it is this it is this it try the
combination but based on Moore's law the
Hammers get more powerful every year
more processing power more processing
power and with networks never computing
you can get multiple devices working on
the problem the same time and with cloud
platforms you don't even have to
purchase it right you can just rent the
processing power from the cloud or you
can build new hammers so these are Asics
this is application specific integrated
circuits and all these things do if you
know anything about cryptocurrency these
are miners and all that they are
programmed to do is generate hashes they
are extremely fast at generating hashes
there's also chips that are very good at
math so this is a an NVIDIA GeForce chip
and this is a GPU GPUs are very good at
making Mac mathematic computations so if
you're going to try and break some
encryption this is fantastic they also
do really well at generating hashes and
we won't even get into the quantum
problem all right there are some
algorithms that are available in PHP
that are considered quantum secure and
it's not because they can beat quantum
computers it's just that the algorithms
were made and with a type of complexity
that makes it difficult for the current
quantum computers to do but nobody is
going to be using quantum computers to
break your encryption today it will be
the quantum computers of tomorrow so
we'll see where that goes
but there are ways to fight all that
power and algorithm complexity is one of
the top kids
they're harder math requires more
computation so the difference between
algorithms before and algorithms today
is that the new algorithms are more
computationally complex it requires more
CPU to generate the encrypted value or
decrypt the the encrypted value back to
plain text and history is littered with
algorithms that were too easy to
brute-force em crypt is no longer in PHP
that explains everything right it had
algorithms that were so old and so
outdated and the fact of the library
itself was it was taken away because it
was too old but most of the algorithms
that were available weren't even
considered safe ok so when I started
using PHP a lot
ten years ago Triple DES was considered
safe it's now considered completely
terrible don't use it
AES is the new standard but now that's
changing as well with Lib sodium so it's
constantly evolving to create more
complex algorithms large keys are also
very helpful depending on your algorithm
specifically very large prime numbers in
asymmetric encryption algorithms so your
everyone here have to update their
website to something larger than a 1k
key a year and a half ago for google
nobody post website and Google said you
need to change this so we're going to
lower your rankings okay so Google live
was about a year and a half ago said if
you don't have a like I think it was
three years ago they said if your site
isn't secured by SSL you're gonna drop
in the rankings and everybody said oh no
SSL and let's encrypt was born all right
the easy way to the easy and free way to
do SSL shortly after that they said 1k
keys are not enough because there are a
lot of sites with 1k he's out there so
2k keys are required and that's what we
mean by large keys what that what a what
a 2k key is is that's a 20 mm 48 byte
integer
it's a very large integer and it's a
it's not just an integer it's a prime
number so just finding a prime number
that size is very difficult doing math
on it's even more complicated which
makes it difficult to brute-force if
you're using symmetric encryption your
larger key means they're going as they
try and brute force it's more
combinations that you have to try which
makes it again more difficult so the
larger the key size the more secure
system resources requiring large amounts
of sis immune resources can prevent the
ability to use the things that you're
not expecting to use something like an
ASIC or GPU they're very good at doing
little things very small computations
but if you require that they use two
threads they can't do that or if you
require that they use a hundred and
hundred Meg's of RAM they can't do that
either or even a Meg of RAM on most of
them so you can increase the complexity
by adding in the requirement for using
memory or using a number of threads
which is what the new password stuff
does for for Lib sodium and the argon to
I implementation iteration so in
iteration you're just doing it more
times right so whether it's more
substitution inside of your encryption
algorithm that's part of making them
more difficult is that they do more
substitution rounds they do more
mathematic rounds your binary
mathematics makes it more complicated
and makes it more expensive to do and
then password hashing is the big one
right where you just do it again and
again and again and again and again
again as many times as you can bear and
that will double do that so the other
tool for cracking is crypt analysis and
graph analysis and I show the the puzzle
up here because in World War two
these are the people they would find to
break codes they would find people who
are really good at crossword puzzles
because crossword puzzles you'd have a
question you might have two or three of
the letters and you have to come up with
a word that would match so you'd have to
have the subject matter and a couple
hints and they could find the words
which is basically what crypt analysis
is today we use machine learning alright
we don't need people we have machines so
mixing the knowledge and identifying the
patterns to fill in the blanks it's been
used for years but today brute force is
usually easier but if you could reduce
the cost of brute force you're going
against what you're trying to create
right you're trying to make it more
expensive and more difficult if you can
reduce the amount of effort you have to
spend in brute force by understanding
what certain pieces are most likely to
be then you're reducing that cost for
brute force so entropy we talked about
this little bit earlier cryptanalysis is
fought with entropy removing order and
creating the appearance of randomness
right in computers there is actually no
such thing as random but we can try and
make the parents of randomness as
individuals we cannot do random because
we have our own biases herbs are our
bias and we have we were more likely to
come up with the same if you said come
up with a random string in your head if
you wrote them all down you would come
up without eventually if there was a
large enough list you would see that a
certain number of values would come out
more often than others because it
wouldn't be random because your head
doesn't work that way and computers are
programmed to do the same thing the same
way every single time if a computer does
something random you have a problem we
call those bugs
all right so trying to get computers to
do random can be difficult and
real-world data has very predictable
patterns which is why entropy is such a
big deal in computing so if you take for
example an HTTP message so this is a
very standard HTTP message where you
make a request to get information and
it's going to give you back data
is the response right so I'm asking for
account information and it's returning
me account information so JSON responses
look very similar I can very easily
guess just by looking at someone's API
documentation what these pieces will be
I know that I'm going to be getting a
200 response I know that content types
could be application JSON a very quick
curry will tell me what the server name
and version is and I know what the
fields are going to be all that is going
to always be the same on every response
unless they change the server version or
they change their API so I can very
quickly predict most of the data in this
response other pieces are highly
predictable if I know when I'm making
the request I will know what the
response date is going to be right for
one second I will know and then the next
second I will always know I also know so
I have a second to try and do terrible
things before this is not valid but
honestly how many people will validate
the response times all right so it
doesn't necessarily matter I just have
to test has to be a time if you're even
looking at that header at all other data
also has predictability so dates of
birth there are people that were born
more likely on particular years than
other years there are people that are if
you'll notice birthdays tend to fall on
particular months as opposed to other
months less predictable now based on the
fact that everybody lives in well many
people live in climate controlled
environments people that would be in
this type of database probably are names
there are a limited number of names and
you can definitely determine that a
certain number of names are much more
popular based on the language in locale
that other names so there's
predictability there and then some sort
of identifier most countries are going
to their country identifier becoming
random values some of them used to just
be counters so based on the date I had
no arrange the date of your birth I know
the range of your ID number your country
ID number
again that's changing credential data
credential data is also highly
predictable most services use email for
the username so if I know your email
address which most people don't think is
being terribly private it passed around
on cards it's on every single it's on
your Twitter account it's everywhere
right if I'm if you use that as a
username then I have half of what I need
already to attack you I have half the
credential passwords also have a high
predictability use so 68% of people
overuse their passwords so that means
that I will use a single password on
more than one site I think that's low
but in 2015 that was the value right and
the top 25 passwords so when you get all
the passwords on these nefarious dark
websites these pastebin sites that you
can go you yourself can go find
everybody's passwords on paste bins
today the top 25 of those constituted
over 50% of the passwords so if I get a
password database and I just to try and
the top 25 passwords so I each one of
these items I try 25 times I am 50%
likely to get it I'll be able to hit the
password in 25 tries that's problematic
nearly 17 percent of users safeguard
their accounts with 1 2 3 4 5 6
very scary but most people hate
passwords I hate passwords I have
pledged my life to getting rid of
passwords for the last three years but
they're there and people hate them and
they just want something they can
remember so they will do the minimum
necessary to get past the password
policy most users will change will
choose passwords based on the ease of
recall right rather than entropy so
because of that the reuse the
predictability creates a serious problem
as people who are trying to secure the
web and protect people from themselves
we have to create you know the lack of
uniformity across our data set so if you
take a look at this data set if you're
if you're like me and notice patterns
very quickly you will see things that
are matching these are three years of
the same password right so as that said
15% of your users will have the same
password one two three four five six
right so what you're trying to do is you
don't want them to be able to single it
out because without having to run a
single query against or a single attack
attempt if I can see in the data that
three out of five is the same I'm going
to guess that's one two three four five
six just by knowing passwords or that's
the same user with multiple usernames
but you have you will have commonalities
across the data set right in your
password database twenty-five percent of
the people will be one two three four
five six so all I have to do is go
through there and find it so good
cryptography uses random salts to add
entropy to hashes so you add the salt to
the password and now they're all
different and that's why you put salts
on two passwords so that you cannot use
the known tendencies for passwords
against your database if you're ever
wondering
but nearly every type of data has
recognizable patterns so English as a
language has patterns spaces can be
determined very predictably most
languages spaces can be detected very
predictably single letter words have a
very limited number of characters two
letter words are very predictable as
well
three letter words and then the most
common letter in all the words if you
don't add some randomness to that to
leave very easy to predict what they are
so this is actually using really good
encryption without using entropy so you
can see that this is encrypted
birthdates or just dates right so the
first two are the same we don't want
that but even if they weren't the same
they're all very similar most of the
data in here is the same so this is
encryption using an auth tag which is a
hash this is very modern encryption so
modern encryption doesn't help you
without adding entropy the only
difference in these things is one letter
or two letters to different segments but
in the first segment there's only two
options in the second segment there are
also only two options so this is very
very recognizable patterns so using
randomness in a random Internet Ischl
ization vector and encrypted data
they're all different that's why it's
important to have randomness and
encryption as well as you want to make
sure that that same data isn't the same
so random salts and IVs are necessary
necessary necessary unfortunately it's
easy to get so C spring
cryptographically secure pseudo-random
number generation big word just use
random bytes write PHP random bytes
that's all you need it does all that for
you if the big word you don't even
remember if you need to generate an IV
if you need to generate a salt random
bytes it's going to do all this stuff to
make sure that it actually is random
it's not predictable good because if you
don't
people can based on the time that you
execute it have a fairly high likelihood
of figuring out what that value is when
you generate it so you want to make sure
you're doing it properly
all right I've just thrown a lot of data
at you and it's been like 40 minutes so
what I can tell you is that today you
can do very very simple things use the
password extension PHP has the best
password option on the planet I have
worked in a lot of languages and there
is nothing better it's very simple to
use you can very quickly determine if it
needs to be rehashed based on the new
algorithm you can upgrade the algorithms
in place it has very same defaults just
use it because when you need new hash a
new hashing algorithm you can very
quickly just change a value from
password default to pass one argon to I
and you now have argon to I and it you
can rehash in place so just use it just
use it just use it if you're using a
framework make sure they're just using
it because it makes your life easier
down the road I promise you the disodium
brand-new and 72 documentation is
terrible I'm trying to work on that
there is no documentation all right
the person who wrote it has a patch for
it I'm trying to work to help him get
that patch into the PHP Docs but we'll
see how that goes
but we are working on it and it actually
simplifies encryption if you've done the
corruption before when you want when you
need a key what size key do you need I
don't know when I look at the docs right
it's very complicated very difficult it
just gives you constant to do that it's
very easy to generate the nonce go
through all these things and very
quickly do it right you don't have to
guess anything you don't have to know
anything right you just call the
function pass it there text the key and
the nonce and it encrypts it you don't
have to guess algorithm you'll need to
know strength you'll need to know
iterations it's just going to do it it's
supposed to be simple the only thing
it's not simple is the length and the
names of the functions and the constants
because they are really really really
long I do a talk just on that and
sometimes just the function takes up the
entire length of the screen it's
complicated
but it's easy okay live sodium is easy
the password function is easy and at
least now you know why you should use
them because it's important
introductory books so the codebook is a
really good story telling book about how
cryptography worked over time and it
gave me a lot of insight into why is
this this way why is this that way if
you're interested it's a really good
book if you want to get deep into crypto
cryptography engineering talks about the
if you're a math geek talks about math
algorithms and explains the math behind
it
so if you're someone like me who better
understands physics when you can do the
math this is a good book for you if
you're not one of those people you can
just skip the math and I'll still
explain it pretty well and then serious
cryptography is a new book that I'm
reading that's actually pretty good it
does a really good with randomness there
are websites so the password manual it
actually talks about it fairly well if
you want to use sodium the pecola
documentation is identical to the PHP
the PHP extension and you can also start
using lib sodium today using the Pecola
installation
there's also open SSL and C spring the
information is there as well and then a
lot of things I learned about
cryptography I learned from Wikipedia
because it really has really good
information on how does RSA work how do
I look to go carve work
what's an IDI to 5:09 curve those types
of things so check that out if you want
to get really really into it and then we
have like 30 seconds for questions
questions okay if you have other
questions which you probably do but your
force for time I'm gonna be here all
week
so please just come see me and find me
down I love talking about this stuff
check out the books I'll put the slides
up somewhere so you can go through those
again and thank you for coming
[Applause]